the winner is always the most powerful
and
and and we we throw that phrase out but
no one thinks about what that phrase
means like like who's the most powerful
or the you know or the most powerful
side one but they don't think about it
and they think about power
energy delivered in a period of time and
then you think
a guy with a spear is more powerful than
someone with their fist and someone with
a bow and arrow is more powerful than
the person with the spear and then you
realize that somebody with bronze is
more powerful than without and steel is
more powerful than bronze and if you
look at the romans
you know they persevered you know with
artillery and they could stand off from
800 meters and blast you to smithereens
right they
you know you study the history of the
balearic slingers right and you know you
think we invented bullets but they they
invented bullets to put in slings
thousands of years ago they could have
stood off 500 meters and put a hole in
your head
right and so there was never a time
when uh when
humanity wasn't vying
to come up with an asymmetric form of
projecting their own power via
technology an absolute power is when a
leader is able to control large amount
of
humans they're
facing the same direction
working in the same direction to
leverage uh energy the most organized
society wins
yeah when the romans were
were
dominating everybody they were the most
organized civilization
in europe and
as long as they stayed organized
they dominated and at some point they
over expanded and got disorganized and
they collapsed
and uh i guess you could say that you
know the struggle of human condition
it catalyzes the development of new
technologies one after the other it
penalizes
anybody that
rejects ocean power
right gets penalized you reject
artillery you get penalized you reject
atomic power you get penalized
if you reject digital power cyber power
you get penalized
and uh
and the the underlying control of the
property keeps shifting hands from
you know one institution or one
government to another based upon how
rationally they're able to channel that
energy and how well organized or
coordinated they are well that's really
interesting thing about both the human
mind and governments
that they
once they get a few good and companies
once they get a few good ideas they seem
to stick with them
they reject new ideas
it's almost uh whether that's emergent
or
however that evolved
it seems to have a really interesting
effect because when you're young
you fight for the new ideas you push
them through then a few of us
humans find success then we get
complacent
we take over the world using that new
idea and then
the the new young person with a better
new idea
challenges you and you as opposed to
pivoting you stick with the old and lose
because of it and that's how empires
collapse and it's just both at the
individual level that happens when two
academics fighting about ideas or
something like that and at the uh
at the human civilization level
governments they hold on to the ideas of
old
it's fascinating
yeah an ever persistent
theme and the history of science is the
paradigm shift and the paradigms
shift when the old guard dies and a new
generation arrives
or the paradigm shifts when there's a
war
and everyone that disagrees with the
idea
of aviation finds bombs dropping on
their head or everyone that disagrees
with whatever your technology is has a
rude awakening and
if they totally disagree their society
collapses and they're replaced by that
new thing
you